okay welcome back everybody so today
we're going to do something a little bit
kind of interesting in OD ease so before
we've been talking about differential
equations like X dot equals ax linear
Odie's and now we're gonna start
thinking about kind of the general case
where we have some external forcing on
the system okay so as powerful as OD
ease are adding the ability to force our
system externally opens up an entire
world of systems that we can now analyze
okay so for example we had in the
homework you have this double pet this
single pendulum example and one thing we
can do is have an external torque
forcing to try to stabilize this
pendulum we've looked at the spring mass
damper system and what we can possibly
do is have some kind of external forcing
on this base plate to make this mass do
what we want it to do I mean this is
really the first stages of being able to
do feedback control and stability
analysis for external forcing all kinds
of neat stuff there's a really
interesting problem which is the crane
problem so if you have if you have like
a construction crane carrying a mass and
it needs to turn left and move this you
know to some other position how do you
put forces on this this train to
actually move this mass without the mass
swinging okay so this is the kind of
real life problem that you can solve
with an OD e okay so there's some
differential equation for this mass on a
string this is basic
a pendulum and we're going to be forcing
this pendulum by moving the base points
by turning the crane okay you can also
let out or take in slack and so you
might want to move from point A to point
B with as little oscillation as possible
because oscillations and cranes are
really dangerous you can also do this on
gantry cranes tons of interesting
examples another one is like let's say
that the US and China are in a currency
war that's not terribly unfeasible so
you could have a linear differential
equation that relates kind of the
currency valuation of two or three or
four or five countries different
currencies but you can actually have
external forcing for example I can print
money if I'm the Fed or I can peg the
value of the UN to the dollar right so
there's external forcing we can do to
destabilize or reef stabilize systems
that may naturally be unstable okay tons
of examples this could be the natural
dynamics of a disease spreading across
Africa and this might be the boots on
the ground actually administering
vaccines to people to try to you know
eradicate polio or malaria okay so
things are about to get more interesting
and soon probably next week we'll have
maybe this forcing function I'll just
call it B so A then B next week we'll
start dealing with even more general
nonlinear systems where X is a nonlinear
function X dot is a nonlinear function
of X and there's some nonlinear external
forcing okay so this is kind of the most
general case that we would be thinking
about and next week we're going to be
talking about how to numerically
integrate solutions of OD ease when we
can't solve them analytically so this
week is almost to the end of what we can
do on pencil and paper and soon we're
gonna have to move to computers to
actually solve much much harder more
interesting problems
okay are there any questions before I
dive in about anything we've been doing
so we have a midterm soon it comes out
on Monday any questions about the
midterm yeah now so I will make the
midterm available on Monday I don't know
if it'll be like right after class and
probably be right after class the
midterm will come out after class on
Monday and you will have a fixed amount
of time between Monday and Wednesday to
solve the exam okay I don't know if it's
you know let's say it's two hours I
don't know if it's two or four let's say
it's a four hour exam then I would
essentially trust that you're only going
to take four hours on the exam you can
use any of the notes from the class but
that's it don't google anything don't
talk to any friends don't you know look
at any other textbooks you can look at
any of the notes and your old homeworks
and you'll have four hours to solve the
exam any time between Monday and
Wednesday and you can probably break up
that four hours into like two or three
big chunks okay so if you want to work
on like two hours before dinner and two
hours after dinner that's fine with me
like it's on your honor it should take
about four hours is that pretty clear
yeah yeah so there will be parts of it
where I will expect you to use MATLAB so
it would be a good idea to at least you
know be able to get to a computer that
has some MATLAB access for you know 30
minutes or an hour or two of the exam
and I'll try to be pretty clear about
things I want you to do by hands so
there will some be some things where I
don't want you to use MATLAB and some
things where it's totally fine to use
MATLAB it's a tool I use it all the time
I would expect you know you'd be able to
use it I want this exam to be you know
kind of a preparation for the qualifying
exam so some of it will be pencil and
paper by hand the qualifying exam has
about two times maybe four times as much
stuff on it and
half as much time so yeah so you can
kind of use this exam however you see
fit other questions on the exam it's of
course cumulative up until this points I
will you know ask things that I'm doing
today and on Friday anything else okay
all right so let's start doing some OD
ease with forcing so how many how many
of you remember some methods of solving
o DS that have been forced externally
okay a few of you how many don't
remember any of the techniques okay
there's a method of undetermined
coefficients unfamiliar a little bit's
variation of parameters yeah so these
are things you probably did in in your
undergrad Odie's course if not I'm going
to cover them briefly today but then I'm
going to get on to what I consider a
much more general and powerful way of
solving ODS which is by convolution okay
okay so we're gonna solve differential
equations with forcing and for the
beginning of the class I'm going to look
at systems like higher order ode e's
like what we've been looking at earlier
okay remember you can always take a high
order linear ode EE like this and you
can write it as a system of first order
equations in the first part of the class
we're going to look at the system in
this form plus some external forcing and
in the second half of the class and on
Friday we're going to be looking at more
general matrix systems of equations with
forcing okay so we're gonna start kind
of in the simple case and then build up
okay so when you have a know de that's
linear and it doesn't have any external
forcing so there's no kind of right-hand
side forcing function the
is called a homogeneous equation and if
I add some forcing like I have the same
equation X double dot plus three X dot
plus 2x equals e to the minus 3t alright
so this is my forcing function in time
I'm forcing this system externally this
is called in homogenous or in
homogeneous yeah now homogeneous
homogeneous the opposite that's sorry
homogeneous and inhomogeneous okay and
we're gonna call this the forcing term
okay
so what are some things I could try to
solve this we know exactly how to solve
the first equation we've been doing this
all throughout the class we have like
ten different ways of solving this how
would we solve the system when we start
adding an external forcing sorry you
could guess a solution yeah okay let's
guess a solution so the first part I'm
going to say I'm gonna kind of break
this up so it's a little bit cookbook I
don't want you to think about any of the
math in this class as truly being
cookbook right we're learning the
principles of how to solve problems but
this method really really lends itself
to discrete steps so part one is you
solve the homogeneous equation ok so we
solve the first equation to find the
homogeneous solution and we know what
the solution is right we would compute
the characteristic equation which is
lambda squared plus 3 lambda plus 2
equals 0 that would give me I gain
values lambda equals plus 1 and plus 2
minus 1 and minus 2 sorry what
- right minus 1 and minus 2 that's this
seems like I'm messing should this be
plus
alright let's solve this from scratch
okay so I have e to the lambda T equals
X X dot is lambda e to the lambda T X
double dot equals lambda squared e to
the lambda T so I'm going to plug this
all in and I'm going to get lambda
squared plus 3 lambda plus 2 e to the
lambda T equals sorry e to the lambda T
equals 0 so I need this to equal 0 right
and I get got lambda plus 2 times lambda
plus 1 equals 0
I see and now that lambda has to equal
minus 1 or minus 2 thank you okay good
if I ever make that kind of a bonehead
mistake please feel free to tell me
it does happen often okay so the
homogeneous solution is X of T equals
some constant e to the minus T plus some
other constant e to the minus 2t right
stable system ok so the second part now
we're going to guess what a special
solution X would be that makes this left
part of the equation equal the right
part okay and that's called the
particular solution of X so now we're
going to find a particular solution of
the double star equation and the best
way to do this for simple forcing
functions at least and when I say simple
I mean anything that's exponential or
cosines and sines anything that looks
like a solution of a linear differential
equation we're just going to assume that
x equals some constant times that's you
know dick
hang or growing mode so we're gonna say
okay our X particular solution in time
is going to be some constant times e to
the minus 3t
okay now guessing this kind of solution
will not work for arbitrary functions
for arbitrary forcing if I give this
thing some nasty cosecant plus
hyperbolic tangent function I'm not
going to do well by just guessing that
my particular solution is some constant
times that it's not going to work but it
does work for you know exponential
functions and cosines and sines because
those are naturally solutions of linear
differential equations okay and what we
do is we just plug this in to the
equation and we solve for the constant
that makes this equal to zero so again
we have X particular dot is minus 3k e
to the minus 3t X particular double dot
is 9k e to the minus 3t I think so I can
take each of these and plug them into my
equation and I get okay X double dots is
9 K 3 X dot is minus 9 k and plus 2 X's
plus 2 K all of that times e to the
minus 3t and that equals e to the minus
3t ok so the reason I said that you can
guess the particular solution for simple
forcing like Exponential's and cosines
is because the derivatives of
Exponential's are the same Exponential's
right so we know that we're going to get
this nice algebraic equation in K okay
so my 9 KS cancel and I get 2 K e to the
minus 3t equals e to the minus 3t so k
equals positive 1/2
okay so the particular solution to this
XP is equal to 1/2 e to the minus 3t and
we've just verified that if I plug this
in to my equation it actually does
cancel out the left on the right sides
right they actually do equal each other
ok no magic just for simple forcing
functions you know there are additional
solutions beyond the homogeneous
solution that also satisfy this
differential equation in fact this is
necessary you need this piece to make
this equation true
you can't do it with just e to the minus
T's and either the minus two T's you
need this 1/2 e to the minus 3t to make
the Doublestar equation equal to zero
okay ok questions at this point I'm
trying to build up simple examples of
external forcing where our intuition
about what the solution would look like
makes sense ok this is called the method
of undetermined coefficients I literally
had an undetermined coefficient and I
had determined it okay so it should be
called the method of determining
undetermined coefficients the third part
is really simple this is part two so the
third part is that I add my homogeneous
solution to my particular solution ok so
the full solution X of T equals some
constant k1 e to the minus T plus k2 e
to the minus 2t plus exactly one half e
to the minus 3t I needed to determine
this coefficients and so this is the
solution to the double star equation ok
any constant one and constant two will
work so why is it that I can just add my
homogeneous and my particular solution
and the answer is a solution
sorry
right so this homogeneous solution if I
plug it in I get a bunch of terms that
cancel out to zero and so it really
doesn't affect the action of this
particular solution cancelling out this
right-hand forcing term there's a kind
of another reason beneath that which is
it only works because my OD e is linear
and what linear means is that
superposition of solutions works if I
have two solutions X 1 and X 2 then X 1
plus X 2 is also a solution that is the
fundamental most important property of
linear systems it is it's why we can do
almost everything we do in linear
systems analysis it's why k1 and k2
could be anything it's because e to the
minus T is a unique solution and e to
the minus 2t is also a unique solution
and any linear combination of them is
also a solution because the OD e is
linear so we'll talk a little bit more
about this we'll talk a little bit more
about this soon but I want to get it in
your mind that this idea of linear OD
ease you can add up linear combinations
of their solutions and they're still
solutions that's not true for nonlinear
Odie's at all ok good ok so that's it
that's the solution
what about k1 and k2 how do I wonder
what's the meaning of k1 and k2 here
initial conditions so they are still
exactly the same k1 and k2 that are
needed to satisfy my initial conditions
ok this third term here if sole purpose
in life is to cancel the forcing or to
make the forcing balance with the OTE
and these terms are the natural dynamics
that evolve the initial condition ok
which is really interesting the solution
is the initial condition dynamics plus
the effect of forcing completely
decoupled if I double the forcing I just
double this term ok it's really
interesting
okay so this is pretty useful but yeah
if you're given initial conditions you
can do either one because they're gonna
give you I think no they're not going to
give you the same thing yeah if this X
really is this whole solution then X at
time zero is going to have a 1/2 do to
this term so it's really going to be k1
plus k2 plus 1/2 and that's going to
mess up my like my initial conditions so
you have to solve the initial conditions
given this this in homogeneous forcing
yeah ok so that's the only way that this
forcing effects this initial condition
solution is by changing the proportion
of these two terms given by that initial
condition okay so the next thing I'm
going to tell you about is called the
variation of parameters this is an
extremely powerful method for solving
ode E's and I'm really torn about
telling you about this because before
computers this was a really big deal
right the method of variation of
parameters could let you solve extremely
complicated time varying OD E's and do
really really powerful things
analytically right you can solve for the
trajectories of planets and machines
without any computers nowadays we can
solve all of the systems I'm telling you
about in Mathematica and it's way faster
and more accurate than what we can do so
in reality I haven't actually used the
method of variation of parameters in
over a decade which is a dirty secret
but I have to tell you but it's still
important to know the idea of how you
manipulate terms in an OD e to get kind
of more general solutions with forcing
because this is gonna come up come up
later so I'm going to show you even if
the only time
you ever use it as for the homework okay
because it's good to understand kind of
the principle of what's happening okay
so remember we have this OTE
and we know that the solution X of T
equals k1 e to the minus T plus k2 e to
the minus 2t now instead of adding an
additional term you know plus X
particular for some forcing what I'm
going to do is I'm going to allow these
coefficients to vary in time they're
going to be kind of general functions in
time so I'm going to allow X of T to
equal you one of time e to the minus T
plus u2 of time e to the minus 2t okay
most of you have seen this it's probably
been a little while and so the idea is
now if I make this external forcing f of
T maybe that's equal to e to the minus
3t like before I'm going to solve for u1
and u2 that when I plug them into my
differential equation everything works
out okay this strategy of allowing my
coefficients to vary in time and be
their own functions is way way more
general and it allows me to solve for
much more general forcing functions that
aren't just exponential decays or
cosines and sines okay you can solve for
really nasty forcing using this method
you can also do it numerically which is
kind of cool okay so we're just going to
jump in and it's kind of a mess so ask
questions if you know I go too fast or
if there's something that doesn't make
sense okay so this is my X now we're
going to compute X dots and we're just
going to use the chain rule so what is x
dot of this equation
okay you one dot e to the U one dot e to
the negative t minus u 1 e to the
negative T plus u 2 dot e to the minus 2
t minus 2 u 2 e to the minus 2 t notice
that i've separated out the terms that
are just u 1 and u 2 from the you want
you two dots so i'm trying to
essentially what i'm going to do is
based on this OTE i'm going to find
constraint equations that constrain the
solution of what you want and you two
need to be to make this equal and the
first constraint equation i'm going to
choose right i have two unknowns u 1 and
u 2 so I can get to constraint equations
and I can solve uniquely for u 1 and u 2
the first constraint equation is that
this term that I don't like looking at
is equal to 0 because if I take another
derivative I'm gonna get a ton of terms
and I don't want to do that so I'm going
to manually set these equal to 0 I have
the freedom to do this I can choose u 1
and u 2 such that their derivatives
times e to the minus T and e to the
minus 2t add up to 0 this is one of my
constraint equations so this is a
constraint one alright so my second
constraint equation is going to be this
actual differential equation itself ok
so now I compute X double dot of T and
what's X double dot of this equation
this first two terms minus u 1 dot e to
the minus T plus u 1 e to the minus no
no no no no minus u 1 dot e to the minus
t minus minus u 1 e to the minus T minus
2 u 2 dot e to the minus
to t plus for you to e to the minus 2t
good that right looks right
I think it's right yeah that's right
okay good so now to solve this forced
equation we just take all of these
expressions and plug them in to here and
it's a mess a real mess okay I almost
don't want to do it but we have to so we
take x double-dot plus 3 times X dot
plus 2x equals e to the minus 3t that's
going to give me my second constraint
equation on u1 and u2 so let's just see
what it looks like ok X double dot plus
3 X dot plus 2x equals okay I'm just
going to collect all of the u1 terms
okay first I'm going to collect all the
u1 terms so I have a u1 minus 3 1 plus 2
u1 all of that times e to the minus T
now I'm going to collect all of the you
two terms from X double dot X dot and X
so I have a 4 u 2 minus 6 u 2 plus 2 u 2
e to the minus 2t ok good we've
collected all of our u ones and u2's now
we need to collect our u1 dots and u 2
dots but they only appear in this
equation which is really nice plus
or minus minus u 1 dot e to the minus t
minus 2 u 2 dot e to the minus 2t equals
am i forcing e to the minus 3t so this
is a really really long nasty horrible
expression but what do you notice about
this big nasty long equation yeah
everything in these brackets all of the
u1 and u2 terms are exactly equal to 0
which is really nice right that's
essentially the idea here of assuming
that X is some arbitrary function times
one of its solutions plus another
arbitrary function times another one of
its solutions means that when I plug
this in to the equation all of the u
ones and youtubes cancel ok because they
get the right proportion of coefficients
from the OD e to cancel so this is 0 and
this is 0 and so my constraint 2 is u 1
dot e to the minus t plus 2 u 2 dots e
to the minus 2t equals minus e to the
minus 3t ok so I have these two
constraint equations for u 1 and u 2
this has to equal 0 and this has to
equal my external forcing ok so we're
almost there
and the idea is for for what I do next
I know it's tiring we need to get a copy
break before finishing this example so
at this point I have two constraints for
u 1 and u 2 and I am so I have two
unknowns and two equations so what I
essentially need to do is solve for u 1
equals something and YouTube sorry u 1
dot equals something
and YouTube dots equals something and we
can do that okay let's just go through I
want to make sure that I do this the
right way so I'm going to use this
equation to get you to dot in terms of
you on dots so you to dot e to the minus
2t equals minus u 1 dot e to the minus T
right because like first constraint
equation equals 0 I can say that this
equals minus that so u 2 dot equals
minus u 1 dot times e to the positive T
I just divide both sides by e to the
negative 2t okay nice so now I have u 2
dot in terms of u 1 dot and I'm gonna
plug it into my second constraint
equation and so I'm gonna get u 1 dot e
to the minus T plus 2 u 2 dot which is
minus u 1 dot e to the minus e to the
positive T times e to the minus 2t
equals e to the minus 3t this doesn't
look a lot better but if I get all of
the you ones isolated I see that u 1 dot
is multiplied by e to the minus T times
minus 2 e to the minus T equals minus e
to the minus 3t we're getting really
close now
okay so now I have you 1 dot x you know
minus e to the minus T equals minus e to
the minus 3t
so u 1 dot equals positive e to the
minus 2t ok what's the last thing I have
to do to solve for u 2 u 1 I mean just
integrate this okay so u 1 of T equals
negative 1/2 e to the minus 2t okay
this was hard-fought let's just recap
what we've done ok
I assumed that to solve this forced
equation I would take my homogeneous
solutions and multiplied them by
arbitrary functions you want in YouTube
i compute all the derivatives and plug
them into my OD e and I choose to
constraint equations that make my life
simpler
the first one is setting these terms
equal to 0 and the second constraint is
the actual OD e itself what I get when I
plug everything in and then from those
constraints I'm trying to solve for what
u one of T equals and what u 2 of T
equals and it's a little bit of a mess
but it's really not that bad okay what
about you two how do we solve for u 2
well we know this part right here that
maybe I'll go to another board
and also there's a constant here right
let's call it c1 right anytime I
integrate something I get an integration
constant really important okay so you
two dot equals minus e minus u 1 e to
the T and u 1 dot equal this so that's
minus e to the minus T which means that
u 2 of T equals plus e to the mine it's
e to the minus T plus another constants
okay not too bad now the final step is
really simple I take the u 1 and u 2 and
I plug them into here and I actually
write down my solution okay so I'm gonna
erase half of this horrible equation
so we have X of T equals this thing
maybe I'll call this k1 and k2
I like k1 and k2 so this thing is minus
1/2 e to the minus 2t plus k1 times e to
the minus T right this is my first
solution to my homogeneous equation this
is one of my solutions and then you - e
to the minus T plus k2 times my second
solution to the homogeneous equation e
to the minus 2t this is u1 and u2 and
when I multiply all this out I get a
minus 1/2 e to the minus 3t plus e to
the minus 3t so I get 1/2 e to the minus
3t plus k1 e to the minus T plus k2 e to
the minus 2t which is exactly what we
got before with the method of
undetermined coefficients so this does
work this is a huge pain and it's really
a huge pain if all we're trying to solve
is this simple exponential forcing but
this same procedure could be used for
way more general Odie's ok so you can
essentially use this to solve for any
system X double dot plus some function a
of T X dot plus some function V of T X
equals some function C of T ok so you
can use the method of variation of
parameters to solve any system like this
actually you can even do third
derivatives and fourth derivatives and
fifth ribs you can do like any higher
order differential equation with
functions for its coefficients if
they're functions of time you can do it
using this method so it's actually worth
all of this pain and trouble because
you get to solve much more general
Odie's with much more general forcing
yeah you can't do it in general for
nonlinear OD ease but the same idea of
introducing a multiplicative function
and then using kind of these integrating
factors like some of these tricks work
for some non-linear OD ease honestly i
would never try them unless I had to
because MATLAB knows all the tricks like
you know it knows 50 years of knowledge
of all the tricks of how to solve these
Odie's
but yeah you probably can solve some
non-linear Odie's this way but but
almost but not not most of them okay so
this is a little bit of a hairy
procedure I really wanted to show you
that there are lots of ways of solving
forced OD ease okay
and these are the classic ones these are
the ones that you learn in a first
course on differential equations you
learn undetermined coefficients and
variation of parameters and conceptually
they're nice even if I haven't done this
in over ten years it's still
conceptually nice that you can do this
but really what I want to talk to you
about is how you would do this for kind
of a general function f of T that may
not be specified even as a function you
can write down it's just data I have F
of T as some sequence of inputs in time
okay are there any questions about this
before before I go on to kind of the
more general case any at all
okay
is that mean that this is clear or are
there no questions because you haven't
tried to solve it yet maybe it's a
little bit of both okay fortunately I
really don't like to emphasize these two
cookbook methods because I don't like
cookbook methods okay I like thinking
about how would you you know it's hard
for me to remember how to derive this
from scratch because it's not exactly
clear what the principles are and what I
want to tell you are what are the
principles for solving more general
systems okay so what we're gonna do in
the next class on Friday is we're going
to look at linear systems like X dot
equals a X and how many of you have seen
some feedback control theory before or
some linear systems how many of you have
never seen any feedback control theory
okay so this is definitely not a class
on feedback control but I want to give
you kind of the mathematical framework
to start thinking about input-output
systems okay lots of systems in real
life taken some inputs they have some
internal dynamics and there's outputs
that we can measure so there might be
some be matrix times some input vector U
and this will be my external forcing or
my control signal this is the thing I
can actually manipulate or force to make
the system do what I want it to do okay
so we're going to talk about forced
systems that look like this
using convolution and Laplace transforms
okay so all of you I think have seen
Laplace transforms at some point maybe
how many of you have not seen Laplace
transforms okay that's fine so we'll
we're only going to use a few key
properties of Laplace transforms for the
next lecture and in 565 we're really
going to derive like Laplace transforms
from the ground up okay and kind of this
last point that I started to make in the
beginning of the class is about
linearity
of systems what does it really mean to
be linear so what it means to be linear
is if x1 is a solution so that you know
x1 dot equals a times X 1 and if X 2 is
also a solution so that x2 dot equals a
times x2 then any constant times x1 plus
any other constant times X 2 is also a
solution ok this is what linearity means
if I have two solutions to this OTE
any linear combination of those
solutions is also a solution sometimes
I'll call these modes independent
solutions of this system might be called
modes ok so if I have like an elastic
medium a rod or something and I strike
it or I excited at one frequency I might
get a pure mode solution but if I strike
it and excite a different frequency I
might get a different mode but I could
add up those different frequencies and
that would also be a solution to those
elastic beam equations so I'm just gonna
derive this from scratch because it's
really really really simple I'm
literally gonna take this solution and
take its derivative and multiply it by
it by eight okay so DDT of X is K 1 X 1
dot plus K 2 X 2 dots right K 1 and K 2
are just constants
and a times X is just a times K 1 X 1
plus K 2 X 2 and this is a property of
matrices that a matrix times a vector
you know V 1 plus V 2 is just that
matrix times V 1 plus that matrix times
V 2 so this is the same as a k1 a times
X 1 plus k2 a times X 2 right this is
just simple like a matrix times the sum
of two vectors is the sum of the matrix
times each of those vectors separately
that's what linear means and if I put
these together I find that DDT of X is
this and it really does equal a times X
because K 1 X 1 dot equals K 1 a X 1 and
K 2 X 2 dot really does equal K to a
times X 2 so both of these equal each
other and so this derivative of the
combined solution equals a time's the
combined solution so this really does
satisfy our OD e so X is a solution okay
are there questions about what this idea
of linearity really means
okay then the last thing I'm going to
tell you today and we're gonna follow up
on this more on Friday is I'm going to
sketch this simple picture of what the
convolution integral is going to look
like for this system okay good so if I
have X dot equals ax plus B u let's say
that my initial condition x is 0 X at
time 0 0 and so all I have is this
external forcing what happens to my
system if I give an impulse in you like
a delta function in you what does that
look like 2x
so if u of t is a delta function right
so it's a delta function in time then
after time zero it's like I started with
this system with an initial condition x
equals B okay so I'll I'll go more into
this on Friday and kind of explain why
this is true but if I if I just give an
impulsive input into you it's like
setting my system up with an initial
condition X at time zero plus is equal
to this B vector and then you know
probably what's gonna happen is these
dynamics are gonna cause this be - you
know oscillate and decay or just decay
or whatever depending on the eigen
values of a and for a generic U of T
let's say that my u function really
looks like this what I'm going to do is
add like this is a train of a bunch of
little Delta functions so every one of
these U of T is going to be like giving
my system a little impulsive kick in the
B direction and each of these is going
to excite some dynamics so this one's
going to excite some damped oscillation
the next little impulse in U is also
going to excite a damped oscillation and
so on and so forth every single time I
have you on I excite one of these damped
oscillations and so I'm just going to
integrate all of these shifted initial
conditions solutions and I get a
convolution integral okay so this is
what we're gonna do on Friday I'm going
to go like in much more detail much more
slowly but we're gonna solve this system
for arbitrary inputs using kind of a
convolution of these impulse responses
in you okay so that's what we're gonna
talk about on Friday all right thank you
you